le département vous présente terre de
trail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la plaine des tamarins c'est un petit
goût de mafate à la mi-course et
plusieurs mois avant cette épreuve des
agents comme jacky sautron se mobilisent
dans les sentiers
bonjour bonjour positif est la nôtre on
prépare son ancien grand raid
la nôtre enfin retrouvé à dos près par
roberto damiani montants seront jacky je
suis conducteur travaux paulo à nef à la
nouvelle marla et roche place
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon le sentier des matériaux t arrivera
mais motivé la terreur nazie
tous ces matériaux là bas avec l'érosion
vinça sa part nous on est là pour
essayer de réduire un petit peu ces
risques là la priorité c'est la sécurité
c'est ça le maître d'oeuvre dans un
autre avant il faut que les gens ils
sont en sécurité puissent à randonner en
toute tranquillité bon dans mafate il
faut quand même faire attention car on
est dans un environnement quand même un
risque il faut il faut être toujours
toujours prudent quand on voit tous ces
gamins qui sont dégringolé qui touchent
pas atteint sa veut dire que dessous ils
ont rien pourquoi les retenir donc on
est presque arrive à une roche mère en
fin de compte
pendant tout le week passage du grand
raid je pense que tout mais mes
collègues qui sont là et ils sont en
train de faire que ça soit un grand
moment pour tout ces coureurs qui sont
de toutes des horizons trois conseils
que moi qui peut donner à aux
randonneurs c'est de respecter notre
sentier qualité environnement les
déchets ne pas prendre les raccourcis
parce que ça abîme de sentiers et
surtout de ne pas prendre les bâtons de
casser des des arbres endémiques qui ont
pris du temps à pousser de faire des
bâtons pour pouvoir pas pouvoir en
donner et en profiter de ce beau paysage
que la réunion nous offrent
quotidiennement à qui j'ai été
impressionné par le blue fait dans les
sentiers quand même mais bon sang tigres
ont raidi appel à moi de me reprend la
course m'ont fait mon sport bah nous
nous fait ça tous les jours oui ma vie
je suis monté les jeux allez allez merci
pour tout on continue h en protège bien
notre sentier ouais je pense que tout le
monde est sensibilisé maintenant daccan
supérieur vue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le département vous a présenté terre de
travail